[Music]
hello and welcome back to steampunks
GameSpot's pc focus show where we talk
about things that matter PC gamers and
the things that happen on your computer
thing yeah I'm in mid trend I'm Joe and
this week we're gonna be talking about
our favourite PC games of 2018 so 2018
was a really great year for games lots
of great games
I'll take PC games as well and so we're
gonna go through a few of our favorites
and then you can let us know what you
think yeah anyway Jess I think I just
want to get started with the PC game I
was most excited about this year and I
know you're a big fan of it to return of
the ER burden it's a really unique
exciting game by Lucas Pope it's one of
those indie games where the entire game
has been created by one person the
creator of papers please yeah unlike
they won't have favorite games of all
time yes papers plays it's like really
cool but super depressing it just got to
a point for me where I just couldn't
play it anymore because everyone kept
dying everyone's already dead in this
game so you don't have that problem but
what you're doing is rocking up to the
air burden which is a ship it's 1780
something and you're there investigating
what happened to the 60 crew members who
have either gone missing or died your
insurance ordered oh yeah which is like
kind of a carrier from the mundane job
of hippest please like you're not a
detective or anything you're just here
to like work out what happened so people
can get their pay yes as you can imagine
it's been a lot of crazy things happened
on that boat and you're gonna figure it
out by inspecting the corpses that you
find aboard the vessel and it will play
some audio of the final moment of that
particular individual and then reveal a
tableau of some part of the ship and
exactly what was happening at the moment
of their death yeah it's still that the
season serves a really intricate
and like exciting and it's their fault
actions even though they're not moving
the visual style is very impressive it's
like a monochromatic art style what I
think is really interesting about this
game is that it easily could have been a
walking simulator but what they've done
is it's actually really quite difficult
and my favorite thing about this game is
how it really respects the players
intelligence so what you need to do with
every single one of these 60 individuals
who perished or went missing
the vessel is figure out who the person
was based on very little information how
they died and who killed them if that's
relevant and it's way harder than it
seems like it's going to be you end up
inspecting the most my new details like
where they might be standing in a sketch
or the bunk number that they were in
which you may say not in their death
scene but in a scene that they were
happened to be in like like four
chapters ago yeah all of these little
scenes take place over the course of
like a few weeks yeah I believe and so I
kind of compare it to a comic book like
you get panels of like events that
happen but it's up to you to kind of
piece in piece together what happens in
between the panel yeah and so drawing
those lines and sort of working out
who's who and the backstories everyone
and how they came to that point it's
really satisfying it's a super clever
game that my actual favorite game of the
year is a game I'm kind of cheating here
because this game is cross-platform
technically that it was only you only
came to switch like really late in the
year and the game I'm talking about is
into the breach which came out on PC
back in March I think so this is from
the guys who made FTL one of 2012's best
games and one of the sort of most
engineering some indie strategy games
that there is so into their breach as
they follow up we take control of the
squad of mechs that have gone back in
time to like try and save the earth from
like giant bugs so very cific grim but
the battles take place on an eight by
eight isometric grid the goal isn't
really to kill the bugs on each map but
more they just keep spawn because I keep
spawning them the goal is to how to
minimize damage to the existing
structures because the structures power
your ability to operate as well as
protect certain objectives you only
spend a very limited amount of turns on
each map so mitigating the damage and
like trying to hold that for a certain
amount of time is makes for a really
interesting dynamic than just kill all
the things and I think that really makes
this work is how transparent the game is
when it turns set itself up you can see
exactly what each enemy is going to do
once that turn is over the next 10 the
next turn so like okay this bugs gonna
hit a building this bug is going to hit
me this bugs webbed me okay how what can
I do to sort of stop the major
objectives from being damaged or how can
I stop myself from being damaged you
can set up these intricate sort of
solutions like it sort of like a
choreographed ballet of butchers and
pulls our big thing in this game is sort
of pushing and pulling enemies into sort
of obstacles like water or like away
from buildings and have them you know
slice the air or push them together and
so they can hurt themselves and sort of
work out the most optimal way to do that
is it's really satisfying so each turn
is kind of like its own little puzzle
things get a lot more interesting once
you start unlocking the sort of eight or
nine squads other squads which sort of
have interesting abilities like you know
being able to ice an enemy but also once
you do that you I see yourself seeing
how all the different like
elements sort of come into play and so
the different things you can do with
them is really interesting and you know
this is a game that you can play over
and over and over and over again like
I've played this game at least once a
week you know for the entire year every
new run is kind of like a host of new
puzzles and unique situations that you
need to use your wits and your abilities
to get yourself out of deciding how to
compromise each turn especially my heart
of difficulties is really engaging too I
mean this is a game where like you can
say okay I'll just sacrifice this guy
for the greater good this turn and like
just deal with it definitely one of my
favorite games this year but maybe of
all time like I think these guys know
how to design a good a strategy game I
got to play more of this game alright so
the next game I want to talk about that
I really loved on PC this year was on
the vowed and unev odd I think it's a
game we talked about on this show early
this year
it's a point-and-click adventure game by
watching I games who one of the real
like bastions of keeping point-and-click
adventure games in the current 2018
zeitgeist and this game is a really
exceptional one they tend to bring out
like about a game of year I think uh
Nevada is actually one developed by what
I like they publish a lot of really
great works yeah there's one like they
actually developed in-house yeah Dave &
Co yeah and the thing I love about Roger
tie games is the voice acting is superb
and they manage to take things that have
been done time and time again I mean the
game has fantasy elements that are
injected into like an alternate reality
in New York City like all these things
have been done but they seem to create
characters that just avoid stereotypes
and writing that
to genuinely care about the characters
without letting the characters fall into
like a sassy persona or you're just the
charismatic or you're just like the
beefcake like the characters genuinely
they feel like people which I think it's
like part of what makes the story so
interesting and what makes the seeing
where these characters go so interesting
yeah Soria is a really interesting
premise yeah yeah so you've been
possessed yeah by a demon which sounds
insane and sounded insane to me when I
hadn't played the game yet but basically
you're trying to chase around what was
happening while the demon was in your
body yeah and you do that by joining
this group called the unev out who are
kind of fantastical they're this a
wizard in there there's a jinn in there
and but they all have quite grounded
personalities as well you'll basically
go on quests and you'll be able to elect
a certain amount of team members which
you'll gather as you go through the game
and the team members you have in your
squad at the time will affect how you
can engage with puzzles there are things
that will be available to do on each
mission that you just can't do because
you didn't elect the team member who's
able to interact with that so you have
to approach things in a different way I
feel like it's really straightforward
the most of the puzzles but the fact
that you can bring her and squatting
sort of customize you play through each
time yeah kind of feels like really nice
yeah and squad based aspect does make it
feel like oh this is my playthrough what
about if you're a fan of point click
adventure games like this is a really
interesting one the characters are
really relatable the locations you go to
a really interesting and the plot points
are not predictable
which i think is really interesting for
any video game story and is especially
good for one that is like so connected
to where the quests go like this one
yeah this is definitely the best new
adventure game this year I feel like
[Music]
when I click adventures that kind of a
genre that you can only really get on PC
and like another one of those is
strategy games and like you can't really
play hardcore strategy games or any
other platform than PC not easily and
this year was a really good year for
strategy games not only did you have a
sieve expansion and a bunch of
expansions for the paradox stuff like
stellaris a new pair you broke the
universe hours and although all those
kind of hard corns but also a few really
really good new ones so Frost punk is a
game where you are sort of taking care
of the last city
on earth I think or something like that
but basically the world is frozen over
and you have a community which is like
building themselves around a sort of
like a furnace like a giant furnace and
the whole thing with this game is like
yeah you will probably fail I think the
story actually only goes for a limited
amount of time and they only just
introduced an endless mode so you're
building a city in sort of rings around
the furnace which adds like a like a
weird new dimension to sort of your city
city builders and sort of city planning
and stuff the whole thing is like the
furnace can only be so hot you know and
so the further out you go the colder
things will be no more unhappy people
will be so that there's a really nice
dynamic in sort of managing the cold
managing the natural disasters instead
of keeping your sort of citizens happy
and also sort of balancing your moral
judgment they're hot a big aspect in
Frost punk is dealing with how far
you're willing to go to sort of make
this new society and sort of keep people
happy and fed in alive and yet frost
plants just a really great game that's
that keeps getting a much new content
and again the kids getting new content
is Battletech which is from Harebrained
Schemes who did a run returns and
published by Paradox and that'll take
also so a flashpoint expansion just come
out but it's if you like sort of next
strategy instead of tactical strategy
and you like patience and sort of the
nuance of like tactical warfare battle
tech is like the game for you it's just
like a really nice sort of free from
tactical strategy game that takes place
a giant maps and like we customize your
mix it's just one of those games where
if you know that you like the genre
going into it you're gonna have a lot of
fun with it yeah I think that's the best
thing that can really set about battle
tech it's a very good game I enjoy a lot
yeah very PC PC game PCK well speaking
of genre that works particularly well on
PC and games are doing really
interesting stuff with that genre I
think if you're a fan of Western RPGs
you really shouldn't go past pills of
eternity dead fire this year sad fire
dad fire my accident getting in the way
it's a really really good RPG and if we
lived in a world where divinity two
didn't come out lush yeah it would
probably be the best W IFE G for a
really long time
unfortunately that game really does
outshine this one but it has more of
that old-school element so if you're
into that if you
looking for more of a 90s to early 2000
survive in your RPG in your isometric
RPG this is the way to go it's also
added some new interesting elements
there's seafaring which shockingly works
really well island exploration and stuff
and you run into a bunch of random
events and it's incredibly complicated
with how you can customize your own
character and your party and the things
that you will be able to do and the ways
you'll be able to engage with the world
will be affected by what you've sunk
points into so there's a ton of
replayability here the game world is
just huge like this is a game you'll
just play for months and months if not
the year there's plenty of ways to
complete objectives in this game by
being clever or by utilizing different
abilities that you've given your
characters instead of just slashing
everybody to pieces and that's really
cool if you finish divinity and you're
really like looking for the your next
RPG on pace eh this one's the one to go
for
sooner or later we do let us know you in
that comment section what your favorite
PC games were from this past year but
for now let's also talk about your
comments on the last week's video about
the fallout 76 PC controls not being so
great you guys had a lot to say about it
and about the game in general but we got
one particular comment from Seth min 75
on YouTube who said looks like they have
kept the same broken controls from
Skyrim back then modest would fix it and
Bethesda would get away with it but not
now not good enough by a long shot
that's a really interesting point
because yeah of course modest as we
talked about last week have solved a lot
of the control in UI issues they weren't
such big fans of in these Bethesda RPGs
but that's now not possible because the
game is multiplayer yeah and I mentioned
last week that just because it's kind of
like being the norm in Bethesda games
previously doesn't mean it's necessarily
good yeah
modding is kind of what makes what
desert game is really great you know
what that's the kind of stuff that
doesn't make me want to play Skyrim on
any other platform other than PC because
you can get so many fixes and add so
much value to the game you know yeah
like playing plots every six just makes
you want to go back and play fallout new
vegas with a bunch of like really
awesome mods yeah I mean they've alluded
to the fact that mods will come but
exactly what there's more to get in be
and if it will actually enable fixes
with stuff like that is hard to say
elsewhere Cameron said on the keyboard
and mouse slash controller statement as
a longtime battlefield player you're
doing a teammate's a disservice on PC if
you regularly pilot vehicles without a
controller he would announce equal
shooting controller equals driving each
are just better at their respective
areas of use to the house specific and
needs uh yeah I think that's really a
good point
have you ever tried to fly a plane with
a keyboard mm yeah it's impossible I
don't know every time I play battle I
feel like I need to have the same thing
like control of them I get in a vehicle
and the key would announce the shooting
it's just it's really hard to sort of
many seconds yeah it's obsessive like
when I think about it but it that
completely makes sense yeah especially
when you're on a team and like it's your
responsibility like it makes sense that
you should have the control scheme that
you need to excel in multiplayer that's
what you're doing
yeah that's everything we have for you
guys this week but do let us know
in the comments what your favorite PC
games were and we'll be back next week
with the PC games we didn't think we're
so good this year so be sure to come
back for that
[Music]